[Music]  my name is david lee miller and i joined  the channel 24 years ago  i took this job because i always wanted  to see the world and this was the next  best thing i was covering the  israeli-palestinian conflict  suddenly there was  automatic machine gun fire you can hear  the gunfire in the back border policeman  who had been standing just a few feet  from me  was hit israeli troops returned fire i  was live on the phone  and what kept me  from panicking  was the fact that i knew  i was live on fox and i had to keep my  composure if not for that  i don't know what i would have done  about a year later i met the man who had  been shot turned out he married one of  the nurses that he had met in the  hospital you have to appreciate every  day